you know it's funny I never really
thought about it in the in the social
justice sense but you must get the worse
[ __ ] thrown at you I mean athletes in
general I don't mean you specifically
but I'm sure you get your share
but just athletes are being yelled at
and abused and the worst and I'm sure
it's racial and religious and all kinds
of stuff especially probably in some
international play although you say as
you said Australia's a little
safeguarded from some of that go back to
Australia you don't belong here and all
that kind of stuff and it is what it is
you know it's not great to hear but
that's that's their opinion and the
reason why it's acceptable to for me to
hear that is because I make millions of
dollars that's the answer that everyone
will give you you make a lot of money
deal with it why
mostly same people bitching and crying
about someone calling labeling them male
and their whatever you know when they in
between or they're not sure they are all
that kind of stuff where you know we
hear that kind of stuff all the time you
know run out of the tunnel you you some
absolute crazy stuff you know from
course I fans but that's how it is I
mean you go change so I think what
you're saying is that it's easier to be
a heterosexual cisgendered white rich
man is that what you're telling me
what's it yeah of course it is I was I
was born with a money tree in the
backyard of course you know that really
naturally that's always gets me you know
if you do some research go and look how
the Balkans are doing economically you
know my family my parents came to knock
came to Australia with absolutely
nothing and built their life up being
laborers making a 60 70 grand a year
towards the the good days you know I
still remember the recession in the 90s
in Australia where we didn't have a loaf
of bread on the table for weeks on end
you know I was reading the same old food
only that I have you know a short shower
every night and that kind of stuff and
I've been through all that
I've had I've had all kinds of crazy
jobs as a kid growing up and and helping
the data and the workshop and all that
kind of stuff so I've dealt with that
end of things so I appreciate where I'm
at right now hundred percent yeah it
always gives me when it's like oh you're
a millionaire shut up but you know what
I have lived that life of a blue-collar
worker probably in a law that a
blue-collar worker where you live
to check yeah and by the way although I
would love to I would drop everything to
be an NBA player they're not looking for
a 40 year old 5 foot 11 guy with bad
knees right I was born seven foot so I
was automatically an NBA player and
obviously you have those those
privileges of being born big you know
cuz because although all the six seven
our trainings is a kid they fade no
factor it was the fact that I was tall
right right it was just privilege all
the way through but but you're making my
point which is you guys bust your asses
now I'm not saying I know there are
plenty of people that are digging
ditches busting their asses too for
obviously a ridiculously to low amount
of money but you do work hard I mean
people think it's like you just show up
to the games or whatever but from every
book that I've read about you know my
favorite athletes every bio and
everything there's like you guys are in
pain a good portion of the year just
from the work and out just so that you
can play at that level yeah no doubt
first and foremost there's no better job
in the world for me I mean I'm playing
playing a game that I love as a kid and
getting paid a lot of money for it
should I be paid a lot of money for it
who can say probably not but I'm making
more money than I should should any
person should ever make God Park you
banned Don't Tell Cuban but in the grand
scheme of things you know it goes on how
much your company or the business is
bringing in and it gets shared out
obviously but there's a lot of work
behind the scenes you know you know I've
had a lot of I've had a lot of tough
injuries for out my career but I bounce
back from all of them putting an extra
star with masseuses chiropractors
acupuncture I sports you know just just
after after this interview I'm gonna lie
down on the floor and stretch for 30 or
40 minutes to get the body right so
there's a lot of things that go on
behind the scenes and that's a part of
being professional athlete it's not a a
2 a 3 hour job that you just see in game
time so you have to put the work in to
try and prolong your career and and just
like any other job but obviously you
know firefighters police officers those
kind of people I think I definitely
should be notches higher than athletes
as far as what they're doing on a daily
basis risking their lives and and
helping the community even people you
know drive ambulances and stuff like
that I think you know they're the real
heroes of the community where we're
obviously the corners idols but in the
grand scheme of things I think most
people are probably more important yeah
what do you think about the way that we
all view athletes we put them on these
pedestals not just that we treat them as
heroes but
moralize them in like a really strange
way you know like when LeBron left
Cleveland people that loved him were
suddenly burning his jersey then he goes
back to Cleveland they love him but
someone goes somewhere for more money
now he's a sellout or if he does that
like we we hold every athlete's decision
as if they're supposed to be Lee's like
superhuman things that shouldn't do make
decisions the same way the rest of us
make decisions by you doing what's best
for your family or going to this city
because it's better whether for you or
your kids we'll have a better education
had that but we we want athletes to be
like just the end-all be-all to
everything
well they look as heroes and villains
and that's that's Carl we get from from
athletics the sports in general and I
think it's one of those things you just
gonna deal with as an athlete you know
we are human we make mistakes I go to
the bathroom the same way as if what he
else's world you know we get annoying
things we're happy about things were up
and down like anybody else that's just
the way we are but obviously were looked
upon as a superhuman machine sometimes
that you know don't have a heart or have
feelings and stuff like that and and
that's just that's something you got a
you know deal with Steve Kerr Xcode I
had in Golden State he'd always
mentioned that you know you guys aren't
only paid for what you do on the court
you're paid for a lot of the things that
go on off the court being a public guy
24/7 not being able to walk down the
street sometimes not being able to go to
a movie with you kids without people
taking photos and stuff like that so it
was a very valid point of what I
remember to this day yeah have you ever
seen any any guys teammates or just
players that you knew in the league that
simply they were they were great
basketball players like they knew how to
play the game but they just couldn't
deal with the other part because
sometimes I I can't think of someone off
the top of my head but like sometimes I
see guys that they seem just sort of a
little uncomfortable in the spotlight
part of it and you can sense that
actually does affect their games versus
guys that love the spotlight that love
the crowds and all that so it like
brings out the best in them guys that
just don't want that that other piece
and it actually affects their careers
yeah 100%
I mean there's those those I went to
college for two years and then I was
drafted and handed 5 million dollars for
their season haven't had one know what
to do with that I don't
how am i trained or prepared to - now
your names in lights you know now people
know who are you become a target for
girls in my clubs will be targeting you
to try and you know dude or whatever and
get you some trouble you guys trying to
rob you all that kind of stuff you
driving a flashy car and all that so
there's no really there's no programs
and stuff like that can training me for
that and P for that it just becomes life
lessons and you living even learn as you
go so when I see an athlete that's
really young NFL NHL NBA make a mistake
and a bad mistake you feel bad for them
because you know how would they're
prepared for that or being told what to
expect but the guys aren't feel sorry
for the guys that have constantly do the
same thing over and over again make the
same mistakes generally you're smarter
guys will make that mistake once and and
then generally not make it again and and
have that life lesson but it can make
you kind of be you know isolate yourself
a little bit and not trust people as
much as you probably should which is
definitely an issue I have to this day
you know I've experienced all kinds of
things I'm off the call with with with
so-called friends and family so it
definitely changes your perspective on
things yeah I mean people basically they
probably view you as a bank sort of like
everyone that everyone wants a piece
right yeah walking ATM that's I struggle
to say no early in my career I really
struggle to say no I'd always try to try
to be nice and say look that's a great
that's a great business proposal let me
let me read through it blah blah blah
blah blah later on in my career I've
realized being an [ __ ] works much
better so Chum is not right and I don't
care who it is whether it's someone
that's really close to me or not if I
don't like it I say no and if you can't
handle that bad luck
well now you can send up the Kuban so
you have been easy out yep
that that's the way to do it what is it
like being around so many people that
have so much money all the time because
as you said you didn't come from much
I'm sure they're I would venture to say
that most of the NBA players probably
didn't come from much but some certainly
did and some went to elite prep schools
and all that kind of stuff but just
being around a bunch of guys basically
in their 20s early 30s that all have a
lot of dough
um it's interesting you know you see you
see all kinds of things as a
professional athlete you know I have a
very good book when I'm done it's just a
lot well a lot of good things a lot of
bad things you see you know I can see
sometimes young guys come in the league
and you can I can I can point out the
hangers on the guys that won't be in
their lives in another five or six years
you can point out the people that
they're just there all those checks are
rolling in and and all that kind of
stuff so it's very very interesting
there's there's you know athletes are
competitive so when you read these these
stories of guys going broke you can you
can somewhat see why sometimes you know
you know player a buys a Ferrari player
B then wants to get a lamb being it's
nicer and and that competitiveness stems
into cars to jewelry to houses all that
kind of stuff and that's where where it
gets a little bit dicey and guys can
kind of you know blow their whole checks
on petty things but that's where you
know some of the programs that are
unions and the Lea is that a better job
over the last decade of bringing some
people in that have been through that
and it can kind of explain that to guys
like hey no it's not important that you
you have XYZ now it's important you kids
out of school for the next eighteen year
that you can still live a nice life and
it does get don't get tough beyond one
end or a competitive offer for as much
as we are for yeah
how much do you guys are you guys just
aware in general that the the shelf life
for your career you know if you played a
thirty-five that's basically oh you're
old at 35 in the NBA that you have your
whole life where most people are just
getting their groove going at 35 you
know they're right in the heart of their
career or whatever it is
now you guys really I'm sure plenty of
guys just retire straight out and
hopefully make good investments but for
a lot of you guys you're gonna have to
figure out the rest of your life the
guys think about that yeah now put
together a plan the loss policy to you
so I can transition nicely to retirement
from basketball retirement I felt
politics in your future
I don't think so the only thing I lost
very long
honestly don't think I'll be I didn't
think you were gonna last long I think
it'll be real quick
but yeah gets it up thrown in jail yeah
a different thing about retiring from
boss
mid-30s I'm gonna have some things I
want to transition to in the business
world
the nice thing I have is that I'm gonna
have some some stuff that I'm gonna do
business-wise and off the core and
everyday work type stuff but being being
able to set myself up properly with
money and whatnot means that if I wake
up on a Monday and I don't want to go to
work I don't have to go but I still
still want to be doing something to be
passionate about certain things and
certain businesses that I have in
Australia enjoy working with kids and
some academies with basketball and stuff
like that so you definitely don't want
to just retire and think hey I can sleep
I can sleep in till 11:00 every day and
and just chill out with the boys because
he soon come to realize that those boys
have jobs that are my tool 5cu the fear
for days you're pretty bored there's
only so many video games you can play
right yeah I'm not a huge video game guy
which would show you right now I've
still got a Super Nintendo set up right
here oh you hate old-school Super
Nintendo old-school with the proper Juan
oh very nice
I want Tetris I play the old school
stuff a little bit just 20-30 minutes I
told the new stuff yeah that's funny I
was telling the story a couple weeks ago
on the show but I was playing with my my
six-year-old nephew we were playing like
Wii U one of the new ones and like my
hands hurt I could barely play so I just
downloaded I downloaded old 8-bit you
know NES games and Sega Genesis games
and that's what we played and I was like
all right I still I still got a little
something left you know yeah that must
be rough though because the the guys
that a lot of the ball players are big
gamers right yeah they are yeah and
that's I think it's great you know if
you're you're into that kind of stuff it
keeps you keeps you out of trouble if
you wanted to stay at home and play NBA
2k or whatever it is I think there's a
lot worse things you can't be doing so I
know a lot of guys young guys do that to
stay off their legs and just kind of
stay out on the streets as they say so
it's not a bad thing but it is a bad
thing if you're a seven-year-old kid
here on the couch eight hours a day and
just eating and drinking soda then it
can obviously become an issue I know now
I understand why my parents were always
trying to get me outside I didn't I
didn't understand it back then but I get
a man if I was inside if there's a
weekend come on parents gonna work on
the weekends generally yeah and it was
sunny outside and I'll sleep on the
couch my
I was mowing the lawn or doing whatever
I was in all sorts who would absolutely
kill me and you'd be like oh nothing to
do today okay come with me so I knew it
was a weekend my dad was home I was at a
house I'd go as far from the house as I
cooked my bike or my football my soccer
ball basketball and just get the hell
out of there
well I assumed he would put you on a
kangaroo and you take your boomerang and
you'd go get a fosters right I think
that's how it works
all right cool before we wrap up you
know you were talking about sort of the
tolerance that players have and we're
saying how sports is kind of the great
equalizer you know and last season
Jason Collins was the first openly gay
player in the league did anyone care it
seemed to me that the media made such a
big deal out of it which is just what
the media asked to do I get it and that
Jason Collins kind of he did something
like he was past the point of really
being a productive player in my opinion
but he sort of just took the bullet and
said you know what I'm gonna be the
first one I don't know that even played
more than 20 minutes the whole season
but said I'm just gonna do it and
whatever and the media goes nuts did any
of the players carry did you find anyone
that really was upset or bothered by
this not really I mean the end of the
day for us is capable the ball in the
hole and can you play basketball you
know all that other stuff that with
almost a sec stroke there but you know
actually can perform I think we're past
any professional sports where what are
we doing off the court or whatever your
passions are whatever you love life is
everything okay if you complain complain
yeah I love it I love it well it was a
pleasure talking to you man and I've
been a fan for awhile and I appreciate
it good luck in Dallas and yeah I mean
if Cubans looking for just maybe like a
13th guy like I don't have to be on that
the active roster if maybe you could
just put in a good word you never know
you never know you got a dream right all
right well thanks a lot Andrew and for
more on Andrew Bogut check them on the
Dallas Mavs this season and his website
is Andrew Bogut calm
you